Salut ! C'est la fin de ces 32 vidéos, où on s'est fait une énigme par jour pendant 32 jours, à l'intérieur du défi une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Dernière vidéo, dernière énigme.
Je commence par vous donner la réponse de l'énigme d'hier et à la fin de la vidéo après la outro je vous mettrai la réponse de l'énigme d'aujourd'hui.
Et à partir de demain donc, on reprend la chaine avec un format normal, une vidéo par jour pendant un an, avec le calendrier normal que vous trouvez dans le descriptif.
J'ai fait ces vidéos donc en avance.
Je vous l'ai dit, au YouTube Space. Je vous ferai voir à la toute fin de la vidéo, je prendrai un petit peu quelques plans du plateau.
Ça veut dire que là, dans le vrai rythme de diffusion des vidéos, moi ça fait quelques jours que je suis au taquet pour vous préparer les nouvelles vidéos.
Bref ! Réponse à l'énigme d'hier.
Si vous ne l'avez pas vu, pensez à aller la voir tout de suite.
Réponse, c'est que Pierre n'a pas de voiture du tout !
Et non ! Pas de voiture.
Alors comment on sait qu'il n'a pas de voiture ?
Pourquoi ?
Et bien on va prendre des exemples:
Si le premier énoncé est vrai, alors le dernier l'est aussi.
Et comme on sait que deux énoncés ne peuvent pas être vrais, on est obligé d'éliminer le premier et le troisième. Directement.
Mais si le deuxième est vrai, ça voudrait dire que le troisième est vrai aussi.
Donc le nombre de voitures est forcément 0 !
Ca ne fonctionne vraiment qu'avec 0 voiture.
Oui je sais que dans les commentaires vous allez dire: "Oh ! C'est quoi cette embrouille ?!"
Il fallait bien que je vous embrouille un petit peu sur au moins l'avant dernière vidéo, mais en tout cas, ça fonctionne en toute logique.
Et en parlant de logique, l'énigme d'aujourd'hui l'est beaucoup plus.
Cette série de vidéo, je vous l'avez annoncé, je la fait au YouTube Space .
Merci d'ailleurs pour le décor, le matériel et tout le soutien qu'ils me donnent.
Ça me permettait deux choses de faire cette série de vidéos.
Ça me permettait déjà moi de vous faire un petit break pour cet été,
et de pouvoir écrire d'avantage de contenu pour la rentrée.
Donc ce que j'appelle "la rentrée" c'est à partir de demain.
Cet été forcément, je le sais, je ne vais pas prendre le temps de répondre exactement à tous les commentaires comme je fais habituellement.
Je vais tous les lire, c'est sûr, mais pas forcément y répondre.
A partir des vidéos de demain, par contre comme d'habitude, je reprendrai le temps, en fin de semaine, de répondre à tous les commentaires de la semaine qui auront été mis.
Je donne donc la dernière énigme, et je vous donnerai la solution après la outro de cette vidéo là.
7 boules ou 7 balles ont une apparence complètement identique.
La même forme, la même taille, la même couleur.
Mais l'une des 7 boules est légèrement, mais légèrement, à quelques grammes près, plus légère que les autres.
A l'aide d'une balance à plateau,
vous savez les balances où il y a un plateau de chaque coté,
et si on met quelque chose de plus lourd ici, ça fait ça,
ou ça.
Comment déterminer en 2 pesées seulement, quelle est la boule la plus légère ?
Je vous laisse réfléchir à ça.
La solution elle est après la outro, vous n'êtes pas obligé de la regarder aujourd'hui.
Vous pouvez attendre jusqu'à demain par exemple, pour vous laisser 24H pour trouver la solution.
Je suis ravi qu'on reprenne le rythme habituel demain, pour la dernière ligne droite du défi d'une vidéo par jour.
Pensez à vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait.
Et rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !
[musique]
La réponse c'est qu'en 2 pesées, vous allez commencer par peser 3 boules de chaque coté.
Si c'est exactement équilibré,
si les deux plateaux sont équilibrés,
ça veut dire que la boule la plus légère, c'est celle qui reste là.
Celle-ci.
Elle est invisible !
Sinon, si le plateau bascule,
vous mettez de coté, les 3 balles les plus lourdes.
Puisque vous savez que la légère est du coté du plateau qui a monté en fait. Celui qui monte est le plus léger.
Puis avec les 3 qui vous reste, on fait comme pour la première pesée.
Vous en gardez une devant vous,
et vous en mettez une de chaque coté du plateau.
Si le plateau ne bouge pas et est exactement identique, ça veut dire que la plus légère, c'est celle que vous n'avez pas mise.
Si le plateau baisse comme ça,
ça veut dire que la plus légère c'est celle-ci.
Et si c'est comme ça,
c'est que c'est celle là.
Mais je pense qu'il y en a qui avait trouvé ça.
On verra aussi au nombre de ratio de pouces en l'air, quel été le nombre de personnes qui avaient trouvé la bonne réponse.
Je voulais dire merci, évidemment à toute l'équipe du YouTube Space Paris, qui m'a aidé à faire ces vidéos, par rapport au décor, au changement de décors...
Je vais vous faire voir un tout petit peu le plateau.
Allez, je vous fait voir.
Je vous décroche d'ici et je vous emmène avec moi.
Donc voici ce que vous ne voyez pas.
Alors, oui évidemment c'était bien... bien un faux fond.
C'était une fausse nuit. Tout ça été complètement fake.
Ici, c'était un décor en fait, un petit peu lofté.
Et là c'est tout ce que je pouvais également utiliser pour... pour transformer un petit peu ce décor là.
J'ai hâte de vous retrouver demain dans le format normal.
En tout cas, merci à vous d'avoir suivi ces 32 vidéos.
Merci de suivre le Mental Vlog.
Qui je vous rappelle, est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
N'oubliez de laisser le fameux...
POUCE EN L'AIR !
Laissez un petit com' je prendrai le temps d'y répondre. C'est bon, maintenant à partir de la fin de semaine, je réponds à tous les com' comme avant.
Et en tout cas, je vous aurez lu tout l'été, ça je peux vous le promettre.
N'oubliez pas également de vous abonner avant de partir. C'est très important.
Et rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !